my cousin he'll find you
your cousin
really fun tidbit I fought your cousin
once in the future he is fast faster
he's fast I am faster so this is gonna
be my parts 3 in 4 video for the crisis
crossover just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet there were all
kinds of pop-culture references they
also did another Superman reference so
it's this funny reverse twist on what
happened during Justice League but
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video uh name a new winner at the
end of this alright let's do it
so starting back in the concentration
camp we find out that evil Quentin is
sort of the Lackey of the Fuehrer who is
confirmed as Earth X Oliver and we get a
lot more context and backstory about the
characters from Earth X like he killed
his version of Sarah because she was an
LGBTQ character like that's why they
were talking about what's the pink
triangle for what are the stars for so
we should go without saying most of you
probably remember from world history
that the stars they refer to are the
stars of David for people of the Jewish
faith then you learn about the pink
triangles but we finally meet the Ray
character who is an LGBT character like
that was the big thing they were hyping
up when they introduced him so in
addition to seeing him show off his
powers for the first time you also get
to see citizen cold wearing a version of
the comic book costume probably the most
comic book accurate one that we've seen
so far but if you're not a big comic
book reader the citizen cold character
is actually from the flashpoint timeline
he was in a relationship with iris West
so because we knew that Wentworth Miller
is leaving the DC TV universe the actor
is not going to be on the shows for you
know who knows how long it was weird
that they didn't kill him
and he's staying on earth one but it
just means that when he does come back
eventually it will be this version of
the character
we get to see reverse flashback in the
wheelchair from season one he references
the events of season 1 I built this
place I had to live here for 15 years
I hated every minute of it they give
Felicity the Mangala reference and
that's kind of who reverse flash is for
most of these two episodes where if you
don't remember he was the Nazi SS
scientist who performed all these crazy
human experiments so he says he's gonna
crack super girl like a walnut
totally love the joke about them all
being stuck in the pipeline prison and
unable to break out because almost every
season metahumans find a way to break
out of there and berry bust it out in
the first episode he was so powerful so
talking a little bit more about the Ray
character if you're unfamiliar with him
from the comics he's from the freedom
fighters they're actually doing an
animated series for that so that's why
he's going back to Earth X because
that's where the animated series will
take place that's gonna air on CWC it'll
be just like the Vixen cartoon that they
did just like Superman and Supergirl he
can absorb solar radiation but unlike
them he can also redirect it as energy
blast so whenever he was blasting Red
Tornado with the flash he was just
giving off excess solar radiation but
originally in the comics he got his
powers genetically through his father
who was the Golden Age version of the
character they're a little cagey about
how he wound up on earth X but the
freedom fighters are using the arrow
cave of Earth X like you walk and you
instantly know where you are well I
guess we're in Star City we finally
learned that the doomsday device they
keep referring to during the trailers is
the evil version of the Waverider whose
voiced by Susannah Thompson Oliver's
mother during the first couple of
seasons of arrow so it's a deep cut like
the minute you hear her voice you're
like wait a minute that's all over his
mother this is crazy
we get a couple references to Nyssa and
the characters they've lost Sarah talks
about losing Laurel we're not gonna let
you lose your sister the way I lost my
sister they totally went for Earth X
Felicity bate when Oliver was trying to
pretend to be the evil version of
himself so he could infiltrate the base
and turn off the power dampener but I
think there was actually pictures from
behind the scenes circulating of a
gravestone that read Felicity and
obviously sees Jewish so she would have
been in those concentration camps but
she's a brunette on this planet that's
actually her natural hair color she's
just been dyeing it blonde ever since
that flashback and I think it was season
2 or season 3 where you see the goth
Felicity when she was in college she
just like totally gives herself a
makeover and she looked like that ever
since but it turns out that the big
death of the episode is Martin Stein but
we kind of knew this was coming like the
way he talked about all the plans he was
making for himself the minute a
character does that before a huge battle
like this in there are rumors about the
actor leaving the universe leaving the
TV shows you know that they're probably
going to
but they mention Ronnie's name during
this big crossover no less than I think
at least four times they talked about
the original Ronnie Raymond just
remembering him and all those
conversations with Caitlin
they also referenced baby Ronnie Stein
who's Martin Stein's new grandson so
when he was at the funeral there it just
feels like what they'll do is they'll
grab him from the future when he's an
adult in he'll form the other half of
the new firestorm in it'll be a Ronnie
Jack's firestorm just like in the comics
when jason rusch in Ronnie Raymond were
together but that is still speculation
they might do something about that in
the mid-season finale or the back half
of the season on legends there were no
less than two terminator references when
iris said come with me if you want to
live and then at the end when they take
down metallo and black canary has the
terminator line cisco has never had more
fun I always loved the pop-culture
references during big battles and then
when Felicity and Iris were together in
the air ducts they did a die-hard
reference the Nazis send earth X Red
Tornado after the freedom fighter so it
winds up being the ray in the flash
versus Red Tornado and they give him a
big redesign from the last time we saw
him on Supergirl he looks so much better
and they do give him that moment where
he overpowers them briefly before they
combine their powers just because Red
Tornado is one of the most powerful
members of the Justice League so there
have been a couple times when he's
kicked all of their asses when he's gone
off the rails reverse-flash does his
angry helicopter thing taunting felicity
it also burns her with a pretty deep cut
from Smallville when he says history has
all these legends about all these great
deeds the Justice League characters have
done but nobody remembers who you are as
if there are no Big D's that Blissett he
does look implying that she dies at some
point in the future in the Smallville
reference in there is is that it
happened to Chloe Sullivan when she was
taken over by Brainiac who was from the
future and he said the history doesn't
remember you so if she was still alive
in the world of small build then I think
it's safe to assume that this version of
felicity will live on whether or not
history records any of the deeds that
she does one of the other coolest
reverse-flash references to is when he
says as he's running away
I wonder what face I'll be wearing the
next time we meet
just implying that he will be wearing a
different base and we can talk about
that more in separate bonus
because there's a thousand different
faces that he could be wearing there's a
couple big comic-book twist that they
have not done yet that they could do in
the future so which is wide open to
theory crafting he's just saying that he
will definitely come back at some point
but right now the fight on the flash is
all about the thinker so it's probably
not going to happen right away we
finally get the legends characters back
ray drops a Simpsons reference when he
says in begin and grows his hand to SWAT
that Nazi he's actually been able to do
that this whole time it's just they
don't have the cg budget on legends to
do that all the time they go full
buckaroo banzai with their big lineup
just like they did last year it's just a
bigger version of that like if you saw
the pictures there were a couple people
that were missing that's because they
had to add them in CG later they drop a
couple more Superman Easter eggs
literally when Supergirl drops to earth
and she's caught by citizen Steele and
he says Man of Steel catching the Girl
of Steel but also ethics Cora's death is
the all-star Superman death just a
slightly different twist on that if you
haven't read it in that all-star
Superman storyline he absorbs too much
solar radiation and basically has to use
himself to reignite the Sun when his
body explodes but in this version of
events she just takes her into outer
space that she blows up into nothingness
and I almost forgot there's also a
Superman - Christopher Reeve reference
when Cora says would you care to step
outside I thought all of her killing
himself was very poetic and in keeping
with the character like he's the person
who's not afraid to put someone down
Barry's the one that has trouble killing
people you have the big double wedding
at the end of the episode love the way
they use Diggle he throws up again like
every time the flash super speeds him
around he either throws up or spills
everything that he's holding during the
vows Barry makes a couple references to
Iris being his lightning rod across the
multiverse like in every reality Barry
and iris are always together in some
form or another like their personalities
are different but they're always
together they come as a pair the Oliver
Felicity wedding wasn't quite as
surprising because of the way they were
pushing that so hard from the beginning
of the crossover and there was a lot of
behind the scenes pictures so it was
rumored to be happening anyway so it
wasn't a huge shocker but I was not as
happy with the way they just sort of
tacked it on at the end like oh and by
the way why don't you also do this while
you're doing
but just let me know if you spotted any
other Easter eggs that I didn't mention
during the video the midseason finales
for all the TV shows are next week so
I'll do a trailer video for the flash
after I do my infinity war trailer
tomorrow so if you didn't know the
Avengers infinity war trailer is
dropping in the morning that will be my
next video congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last video
daemon Blackfyre please private message
me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post that
NYX flash video while you wait for
everything click here for the infinity
war teaser trailer and click here for my
part 1 crossover video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight